welcome back to the David packman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in once again today for David
packman I hope David is enjoying his
time away
meanwhile we've got more news to talk
about specifically I want to hit on
something that I touched upon in
yesterday's show yesterday I mentioned
that throughout my entire lifetime
Republicans have not had an actual
economic plan that goes beyond let's cut
taxes for the rich
wanted to expand upon that idea because
I think it's something worth discussing
especially since we're going to be
heading into election season here long
uh not long out in fact we are
technically already in 2024 election
season so it's important to talk to
people about what the Republican party
of today
and of the last 40 years actually stands
for
and the answer is nothing
the Republican Party stands for nothing
I know they have a a party platform I
know they say they like small government
but then they they pass all these laws
letting the government intrude I mean
quite literally to inspect your genitals
that that doesn't seem like small
government at all yet you're passing
laws Republican party at the state level
that will actually allow the government
to inspect your genitals
that that's not very small governmenty
but here's the big point
throughout my entire life and I turned
40 years old two months ago
so I've been on this Earth for 40 years
I was born during the Reagan
Administration
subsequently lived through every other
Republican Administration I have lived
in a red state that has been solidly
controlled by a republican governor and
a Republican state legislature for 25
straight years here in Florida
so I know a thing or two about having to
live under solid Republican Rule and I
can tell you from my experience and from
working in Progressive media for 19
years
Republicans don't know how to govern
it's that simple that is the line
Republicans have no idea what they're
doing what have we seen from them in the
last 40 years and I use that time frame
because that's when the Republican Party
really kicked into this shift when
Reagan came into office but it also
happens to be the time frame I've been
alive so I I like to focus on that
for 40 years the Republican party's
entire Economic Policy whether it's at
the federal level or the state level has
been one idea and one idea alone
let's cut taxes for the wealthy
that's it
that is all that party knows how to do
even with their Republican majority in
the house right now they've already
talked about extending the Trump tax
cuts
you know we're worried about the debt
ceiling we're worried about inflation
you know the supply chain shortages the
gas prices they wouldn't shut up about
last year but went completely silent
when gas prices fell again none of that
actually matters to them now that
they're in power the only thing they've
wanted to do other than carry out
investigations into stupid things
is cut taxes
make sure that tax cuts stay there
part of the debt ceiling negotiations
may include repealing or changing of the
inheritance tax again
because that is the only thing
Republicans know how to do think back
just a few years ago right when
Republicans were trying to draft their
health care bill
and it turned into a tax cut bill like
that's all it had by the time it was
finished it was just a bunch of tax cuts
everything they touched turns into just
tax cuts because that's all they know
how to do and it's not tax cuts for you
or me it's tax cuts for people like them
because that is their economic policy
if they had to actually sit and govern
and deal with the problems that they
love to whine about during campaigns if
they had to try to do something about
inflation if they had to try to
understand monetary policy and how the
debt actually works in this country
they wouldn't know what to do
and I say that because we're watching
them right now try to deal with these
things
and they don't know what to do
but it's not just the issue of Economics
that Republicans have failed this
country on for the last 40 years I want
everybody to to think for a moment when
was the last time that a republican
majority
passed a piece of legislation at the
federal level
that benefited the lives of average
working-class Americans
can you think of a single specific
instance
where they did something like that
because again almost 20 years of working
in Progressive media literally
researching and doing things like this
every day I can tell you I can't think
of a single one
because they don't have one
we have seen them bust up unions which
has hurt the middle class
we have seen them ignore environmental
pollution and destruction which is
harming low-income and middle-income
American people they live in areas that
are you know tend to be statistically
far more polluted than where the one
percent lives
they have done nothing to make your life
better
they've done plenty to make it worse you
know at the state level passing the
right to work laws which is basically
right to work for Less
passing laws that allow massive
corporations to come up Buy in entire
neighborhoods or buy up entire
neighborhoods excuse me and price you
out of the housing market
that's happening all over the country
right now because Republicans are
letting it happen
they don't know how to do anything about
any actual real problems
so what do we do what are we hearing
this week what is the biggest issue for
the Republican party this week
Bud Light
I know you've seen it
I've done my best to try to not talk
about it but you know sometimes you kind
of have to we've got real actual
problems in the country we've got a debt
ceiling crisis we've only got like two
months left to figure it out before we
have to start shutting down agencies and
programs
and you've got Marco Rubio going on Fox
News saying this week that our Global
standing
has decreased our allies are now
abandoning us because of Bud Light
that's what Marco Rubio said
I'm paraphrasing a bit there but he said
all this wokeness
because you've gotten men you know
Hawking Nike sports bras and and a
transgender influencer
promoting Bud Light our allies are now
like Whoa We may have to go it alone
that's what Marco Rubio said
they want to distract you from the real
issues because they don't even
understand the real issues like let's
forget for a moment everything I said
that they don't know how to govern
that's true that's a given but I'm at
the point now where I genuinely think
they don't even understand how to do it
it's bad enough that they won't govern
it's even worse to think that they
literally don't know how to do it which
is why they push the culture War BS on
us it's why we end up talking about Bud
Light for a week it's why they went
after Eminem's it's why they went after
Oreos and Keurigs and Nikes and Yeti
coolers and Dr Seuss and Mr Potato Head
I mean good God how many things have the
Republicans tried to cancel in recent
years because they allegedly went woke
we have seen interviews with Republican
you know Trump supporters out there even
some Republican politicians are on video
ask what CRT is and none of them can
tell you but they know they want to ban
it
they don't even know what it is and they
want to ban it not because it's a threat
but because it gets their low
information base riled up
this is the same base that is getting
destroyed by these Republican economic
policies by these Republican
environmental policies by all of these
know-nothing Republicans
and they just keep doing it because
they're like yeah but we like the
culture War stuff I don't I don't want
to walk into a bathroom and see a guy
wearing a dress taking a whiz as if
that's an issue that affects anybody on
the planet
but that's what they tell us to worry
about that's what they want us to focus
on
because that is the only thing they know
how to do